- [David] Hello readers,
let's talk about summarizing stories.
This is a useful skill for life.
I've found myself describing
the plots of movies,
TV shows and books to my
friends, my coworkers,
my family, and it's also
very useful in writing.
Understanding the plot of a story
is essential to writing about it.
You can't write about a story
if you can't express what happened in it.
So what I want to do today is talk about
creating objective summaries of texts.
Summaries that are free
of opinion, or non biased.
If you're summarizing a book,
you wanna get across
the events of the story.
Objectivity is hard and weird
and has a very specific purpose.
You use it to build the
bones of your analysis.
Once you've got the structure
in place, bring opinions back.
Here are the facts
and now here's what I
think about those facts.
Let me be clear, opinions are good.
Opinions are where analysis lives.
The whole field of literary criticism
would be awfully boring if
nobody ever held opinions
but all that criticism rests
on a basis of objectively
summarized texts.
So let's talk about how to do just that,
how to objectively summarize a text.
Here's what you need to do.
Step one, read the thing
you want to summarize.
You can't do one without the other.
Step two, ask yourself,
what are the important
parts of this story?
Not the interesting
parts, not the cool parts,
but the most essential parts of the story.
Remember we're trying to be objective here
so it's not about including
the parts you especially liked.
So who are the main characters,
where does the story take place,
what happens in the plot?
Step three, pare it down.
Look at all those
important parts you listed,
and cut out everything that
isn't absolutely essential.
Major characters only, setting, conflict,
climax, resolution.
Step four, put it in order.
Write it all out as sentences
in the order the plot happened in.
The idea is to be able to
summarize a whole story
in a handful of sentences,
like a single five sentence paragraph.
And you're gonna wanna paraphrase here.
Whatever you need to say,
say it in your own words
so you can get it across
as quickly as possible.
Ordinarily, I'd say quoting from the text
is an important skill but this
is one time you won't use it.
All right so, those are the four steps.
To demonstrate, I'm gonna
take a fiction piece
from a Khan Academy exercise
and I'll go through that process with you.
Step one, let's read it all,
read this little story chunk.
"'Wilky!' Captain Martello
bellowed below deck.
"'We need your help!' I
climbed the ladder quickly
"and was astonished that I
hadn't awakened on my own.
"Usually I could sense a storm brewing
"hours before it arrived.
"Captain Martello noticed
my look of surprise.
"'She's coming on quick, this
one. Here, grab the rope,
"Help me pull down the sail.'
"Overboard, the waters had changed.
"No longer were they
an inviting green hue,
"they were dark, foreboding.
"The moon above tried to
peek through the angry sky
"but the clouds kept
hijacking her hopeful glow.
"Suddenly, a giant slow rolling wave
"forced my side of the
vessel to dip into the water.
"I tried to hang on but the
lurching wave was tugging at me.
"Captain Martello grabbed my leg
"and managed to yank me onto
Adelina's salt sprayed deck.
"'You're safe,' he said
firmly, 'for now.'"
Okay step two, what are the
important parts of the story?
Okay so Wilky comes on deck
when Captain Martello asks him to.
They're on a boat.
And note here that I'm just
sort of scribbling down notes,
these aren't even sentences.
There's a storm coming
that Wilky didn't predict.
The captain tells Wilky to
help him strike the sail.
The water is a scary color,
a wave nearly washes Wilky overboard
but the captain saves him.
Oh and the ship is called the Adelina.
I think that's a neat name for a ship.
All right step three, pare it down.
So the fact that I think that
Adelina is a neat name
for a ship is opinion
and not relevant.
It's also not super relevant
that Wilky didn't predict the storm.
Or that the water is a spooky color.
So do we have all the
important details in here?
The name of the ship, check.
The name of Wilky and Captain Martello,
the fact that there is a storm.
So part of this is relevant
but not the prediction part
and Wilky nearly being tossed overboard
but saved by the captain.
So step four, let's take all
of that, put it in order.
Start afresh, full sentences, okay.
Captain Martello calls Wilky
up to the deck of the Adelina
to help him prepare the
ship for a sudden storm.
Wilky is nearly washed
overboard by a big wave
but Martello saves them.
That's our strategy, you see?
Boil down the story to its essentials,
strip away unnecessary
detail and rephrase events
in your own words in the
order that they happened in.
Once you've got that squared
away, you're ready to
back up that great big dump
truck full of opinions.
All right bring her in.
(truck backing up beeping)
Let them have it, fellows.
(crashing)
You love to see it.
You can learn anything, David out.